l'échantillonnage est en cours
allez-y ouais nous avons entendu dale appeler plus
tôt que le vaisseau spatial était dans la
configuration y-wing là nous venons de
reconfigurer les rayons solaires que nous avons
acquis lors du contact avec la
surface de l'astéroïde
et ensuite nous entrerons dans une
campagne d'imagerie différente  et ça arrivera
samedi
euh plus tard cette semaine excellent ok dante
c'est ça tu sais que les moteurs
nous ont donné une poussée dans la bonne direction
et osiris-rex est sur la bonne voie pour
atterrir sur un astéroïde la probabilité
est de zéro pour cent ag la vitesse latérale
est de 0,2
par seconde la vitesse verticale
est de 10,2 centimètres par seconde
et allez-y ouais nous avons entendu dale appeler plus
tôt que le vaisseau spatial était dans la
configuration y-wing là nous venons de
reconfigurer les rayons solaires que nous avons
acquis lors du contact avec la
surface de l'astéroïde et puis nous  je vais y aller